vor ort im reichstag wird mein kollege
frank buchwald die debatte beobachten
schönen guten morgen frank man sei ja
handlungsfähig die demokratie nicht
gefährdet wird immer wieder betont
trifft das wirklich zu wenn das
parlament kürzer und unter veränderten
bedingungen tagen muss und wie beim
letzten mal hilfspakete im
schnelldurchgang geschlossen werden
ja hilfspaket im schnelldurchgang das
war natürlich so eine notsituation dass
das parlament arbeiten kann
das zeigt ist und das will es auch
demonstrieren denn tatsächlich ist in
der demokratie ja nun das parlament und
nicht die regierung das eigentliche
machtzentrum und dem dienen diese
plenarsitzungen in dieser verminderten
verkürzten sitzungswoche aber auch wenn
im plenum also im eigentlichen
parlamentssaal nur jeder dritte platz
besetzt ist die abgeordneten sind da sie
verfolgen die debatte an ihren
bildschirmen in den büros und zur
abstimmung kommen sie natürlich dann ins
plenum zurück
was ist denn heute vor allen dingen von
der opposition zu erwarten in
krisenzeiten das sind ja immer zeiten
der exekutive
man sieht das auch an den umfragen die
union vor allen dingen hat unglaublich
zugelegt die opposition hat man den
eindruck findet eigentlich kaum statt
was ist da heute zu erwarten von der
opposition wird es eigene ideen eigene
konzepte geben oder nur zustimmung
also bisher sich die opposition ja sehr
konstruktiv verhalten und hat die
regierung eigentlich durchgängig
unterstützt
auch bei diesem notfall paketen die in
der vergangenen sitzungswoche also so
vor drei vier wochen beschlossen worden
sind
ich denke dass heute die frage der
langsamen eröffnung wieder eine größere
rolle spielen wird also ich glaube dass
dieser konsens kurs den die opposition
bisher gefahren hat der wird langsam
schwächer werden ich denke dass wir
heute in der debatte durchaus auch
kritische töne hören werden mehr
jedenfalls als bisher so wir schauen mal
rein ins plenum
es hat sich schon gefühlt so weit das
möglich ist die kanzlerin ist auch
bereits da bundestagspräsident schäuble
soweit ich das höre spricht glückwünsche
aus oder noch einige punkte zur
geschäftsordnung aber ich bin sicher es
wird in wenigen minuten losgehen wir
können mal kurz reinhören zum
ordentlichen mitglied des gemeinsamen
ausgewählt außerdem soll die kollegen
tun sie auch da einfach sammelt beifall
machen
die kollegin bettina stark watzinger ich
soll auf vorschlag der fdp fraktion als
nachfolgerin für den kollegen dr stefan
ruppert zum stellvertretend mitglied des
vermittlungsausschusses gemäß artikel 60
absatz 2 grundgesetz also man kann es
sehen an den zwischen schnitten das
plenum ist natürlich nicht voll auch
hier werden die abstandsregeln gewahrt
sicherlich schwierige zeiten auch für
die abgeordneten die aber natürlich hier
genau hier sieht man es auch auf der
regierungsbank wie weit die minister
oder die kanzlerin da auseinandersetzen
ich nehme an es dauert noch ein bisschen
deswegen gehe ich doch noch mal rüber zu
frank buchwald ich verspreche aber
sobald die regierungserklärung anfängen
schalten wir sofort wieder rüber ins
plenum
frank es geht ja auch ein bisschen um
das thema europa heute nachmittag wird
es mal wieder eine video konferenz der
staats und regierungschefs geben um
einfach zusehen wie geht es weiter in
europa da gibt es ja große streitpunkte
europa hat sich bisher nicht von seiner
besten seite gezeigt in der krise was
ist da zu erwarten und wird die
kanzlerin auch darauf eingehen
das ist natürlich schwer vorauszusagen
aber ich nehme doch sehr stark an dass
wir auf dieses thema angeht solidarität
in europa euro bonds oder corona bonds
sie jetzt heißen da hast damals ja
eigentlich immer ziemlich klar und hat
gesagt in der gegenwärtigen
gegenwärtigem stand der politischen
union ist das nicht vorstellbar aber
andere formen der solidarität in europa
hat sie bisher natürlich überhaupt nicht
ausgeschlossen ganz im gegenteil dass
europa sich helfen muss in dieser krise
das steht ja nicht im zweifel die frage
ist wie und ob sie sich dazu heute im
plenum äußert möglich ist es man muss
natürlich damit rechnen dass sie nicht
allzu sehr sich in die karten schauen
lässt denn wenn sie alles was sie zu
sagen hat heute morgen schon öffentlich
im parlament sagt dann wird sie in der
konferenz heute nachmittag
möglicherweise beschränkt seien in ihren
optionen und möglichkeiten wir haben die
das plenum weiter im blick noch gesagt
hat die kanzlerin mit ihrer
regierungserklärung nicht angefangen
deswegen bleibe ich immer noch bei ihnen
frank nochmal gefragt gestern abend hat
ja die koalition ein weiteres hilfspaket
beschlossen
da werden erneut kosten auf den
steuerzahler auf die regierung zu kommen
was genau wurde da verabschiedet und
muss das noch durch den bundestag
das muss selbstverständlich noch durch
den bundestag der was gesetzt werden
soll muss natürlich im bundestag muss im
bundestag zumindest beschlossen werden
beim kurzarbeitergeld weiß ich nicht
genau das ist ja eine sache die
sozialversicherung betrifft da hat sich
die koalition heute abend darauf
geeinigt dass in einer art stufenplan
das kurzarbeitergeld angehoben wird
zunächst auf 70 prozent oder mit 177
prozent bei mehr als sechs monaten dann
auf 80 prozent oder 87 prozent so
herzlichen dank frank buchwald ich höre
dass die kanzlerin aufgerufen wurde
wir schauen jetzt mal rein und hören mal
rein es müsste in wenigen minuten
losgehen mit der regierungserklärung der
kanzlerin
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren wir erleben ganz und gar
außergewöhnliche ernste zeiten und wir
alle regierung und parlament unser
ganzes land werden auf eine
bewährungsprobe gestellt wie es die seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg seit den
gründungsjahren der bundesrepublik
deutschland nicht gab
es geht um nicht weniger als das leben
und die gesundheit der menschen und es
geht um den zusammenhalt und die
solidarität in unserer gesellschaft und
in europa ich stehe vor ihnen als
bundeskanzlerin einer bundesregierung
die in den vergangenen wochen zusammen
mit den bundesländern maßnahmen
beschlossen hat für die es kein
historisches vorbild gibt an dem wir uns
orientieren könnten
wir haben ihnen dem parlament
gesetzentwürfe zugeleitet und sie um die
bewilligung von finanzmitteln in einer
höhe gebieten wie sie vor der korona
pandemie schlicht außerhalb unserer
vorstellungen lag ich danke von herzen
dafür dass der deutsche bundestag wie im
übrigen ja auch der bundesrat unter
schwierigen umständen die gesetzlichen
maßnahmen äußerst schnell beraten und
beschlossen hat wir leben nun seit
wochen in der pandemie jeder einzelne
von uns hat sein leben den neuen
bedingungen anpassen müssen
privat wie beruflich jeder von uns kann
berichten was ihm oder ihr besonders
fehlt besonders schwer fällt und ich
verstehe dass dieses leben unter keiner
bedingung allen schon sehr sehr lange
vorkommt niemand hört es gerne aber es
ist die wahrheit wir leben nicht in der
endphase der pandemie
soll man sondern immer noch an ihrem
anfang wir werden noch lange mit diesem
virus leben müssen und die frage wie wir
verhindern dass das virus zu irgendeinem
zeitpunkt unser gesundheitssystem
überwältigt und in der folge unzähligen
menschen das leben kostet diese frage
wird noch lange die zentrale frage für
die politik in deutschland und europa
seien
mir ist bewusst wie schwer die
einschränkungen uns alle individuell
aber auch als gesellschaft belasten
diese pandemie ist eine demokratische
zumutung denn sie schwenkt genau das ein
was unsere existenziellen rechte und
bedürfnisse sind die der erwachsenen
genauso wie die der kinder
eine solche situation ist nur akzeptabel
und erträglich wenn die gründe für die
einschränkungen transparent und
nachvollziehbar sind wenn kritik und
widerspruch nicht nur erlaubt sondern
eingefordert und angehört werden
wechselseitig dabei hilft die freie
presse
dabei hilft unsere föderale ordnung
dabei hilft aber auch das wechselseitige
vertrauen das die letzten wochen hier im
parlament und überall im land zu erleben
war
die selbstverständlich sich die
bürgerinnen und bürger füreinander einig
eingesetzt haben und sich eingeschränkt
haben als bürgerinnen und bürger für
andere
das ist bewundernswert
und lassen sie mich ihnen versichern
kaum eine entscheidung ist mir in meiner
amtszeit als bundeskanzlerin so schwer
gefallen wie die einschränkungen der
persönlichen freiheitsrechte auch nicht
belastet ist wenn kinder im moment nicht
einfach ganz unbeschwert ihre
freundinnen und freunde treffen können
und das so vermissen auch nicht belastet
ist für menschen derzeit grundsätzlich
nur mit einem weiteren menschen
außerhalb ihres eigenen hausstands
spazieren können und immer auf den so
wichtigen mindestabstand achten müssen
und auch nicht belastet ganz besonders
was die menschen erdulden müssen die im
pflege senioren behinderten
einrichtungen leben dort wo einsamkeit
ohnehin zum problem werden kann ist es
in zeiten der pandemie und ganz ohne
besucher noch viel einsamer es ist
grausam wenn außerdem pflegekräften die
ihr allerbestes tun niemand da sein kann
wenn die kräfte schwinden und ein leben
zu ende geht
vergessen wir diese menschen und die
zeitweilige isolation in der sie leben
müssen
diese 80 90 jährigen haben unser land
aufgebaut der wohlstand in dem wir leben
den haben sie begründet
sie sind deutschland genau wie wir ihre
kinder und enkel und wir kämpfen den
kampf gegen das virus auch für sie ich
bin deshalb auch überzeugt dass diese
harten einschränkungen dennoch notwendig
sind um diese dramatische krise als
gemeinschaft zu bestehen und das zu
schützen was unser grundgesetz in das
zentrum unseres handelns stellt das
leben und die würde jedes einzelnen
menschen durch die strenge mit uns
selbst die disziplin und geduld der
letzten wochen haben wir die ausbreitung
des virus verlangsamt das klingt wie
etwas geringeres aber es ist etwas
ungeheuer wertvolles wir haben zeit
gewonnen und diese wertvolle gewonnene
zeit gut genutzt um unser
gesundheitssystem weiter zu stärken
dreh und angelpunkt aller bemühungen im
medizinischen bereich sind die
intensivstationen dort entscheidet sich
das schicksal für die am schwersten von
corona betroffen
wir alle kennen die furchtbaren berichte
aus krankenhäusern in einigen ländern
die vom virus ein paar wochen lang
schlicht überrannt war dass es dazu
nicht kommt das ist das schlichte und
gleichzeitig so anspruchsvolle ziel der
bundesregierung und ich danke unseren
gesundheitsminister jetzt sparen aber
auch den gesundheitsministern der länder
diese unermüdlich auf dieses ziel
hinarbeiten und mit sichtbaren erfolgen
wir haben die anzahl der betten deutlich
ausgeweitet mit dem kit 19 krankenhaus
entlastungsgesetz haben wir
sichergestellt dass die krankenhäuser
die zusätzlichen intensiv
versorgungskapazitäten aufbauen können
so können wir heute feststellen
unser gesundheitssystem hält der
bewährungsprobe bisher stand jeder
corona patient erhält auch in den
schwersten fällen die bestmögliche
menschenwürdige behandlung mehr als
allen staatlichen maßnahmen verdanken
wir dass der aufopfernden arbeit von
ärzten und ärztinnen von pflegekräften
und rettungssanitätern von so vielen
menschen die mit ihrem fleiß und ihrer
tatkraft das ausmachen was wir oft
einfach als unser gesundheitssystem
nennen
ihnen danken wir mit diesem applaus und
in diesen dank möchte ich auch
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
einschließen die an vielen stellen
helfen
eine vielleicht in der öffentlichkeit
weniger beachtete aber ebenso
entscheidende rolle im kampf gegen die
pandemie spielt der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst fast 400 lokale
gesundheitsämter sind das und wenn es
uns in den nächsten monaten gelingen
soll
das infektionsgeschehen zu kontrollieren
und einzusenden einzudämmen
dann brauchen wir diese ämter in starker
verfassung und ich sage ein stärkerer
verfassung als sie vor der pandemie
warnen deshalb haben bund und länder
gerade vereinbart diesen ämtern mehr
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter zu
geben damit sie zum beispiel diese
überaus wichtige ja ich sage
entscheidende aufgabe nämlich die
kontakte eines infizierten
nachzuverfolgen auch tatsächlich
effektiv wahrnehmen können das robert
koch institut wird darüber hinaus 105
mobile teams aus studierenden aufstellen
die sogenannten containments scouts die
dort vor besonderer bedarf besteht auch
eingesetzt werden können von anfang an
hat die bundesregierung sei auch dem
thema der persönlichen schutzausrüstung
gewidmet die versorgung mit diesen
gütern insbesondere mit medizinische
schutzmasken ist schnell zu einer der
zentralen aufgaben geworden und nicht
nur für uns für die ganze welt
denn ohne gesunde erzen und ärzte
pflegerinnen und pfleger nützen auch
vorhandene intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte nichts
die lage auf den weltmärkten für solches
material ist angespannt die handels
sitten in den ersten wochen der pandemie
sagen waren sagen wir mal raus und
deshalb hat die bundesregierung obwohl
wir nach dem infektionsschutzgesetz
nicht zuständig sind entschieden die
beschaffung persönlicher
schutzausrüstung zentral zu koordinieren
und die waren dann an die bundesländer
weiter zu geben und ich danke dann auch
den unternehmen die uns dabei mit ihrer
erfahrung geholfen haben die pandemie
lehrt uns es ist nicht gut wenn
schutzausrüstung ausschließlich aus
fernen ländern bezogen wird
masken die wenige cent kosten können in
der pandemie zu einem strategischen
faktor werden die bundesrepublik
deutschland und die europäische union
arbeiten deshalb daran auf diesem gebiet
wieder unabhängiger von drittländern zu
werden deshalb bauen wir die
produktionskapazitäten für schutzgüter
in deutschland und europa mit hochdruck
aus wenn wir uns fragen was uns zugute
gekommen ist in dieser ersten phase der
ausbreitung des virus so sind das neben
den relativ vielen intensivbetten die
hohen test kapazitäten und das dichte
netz an laboren die experten sagen uns
testen testen testen
so gewinnen wir ein besseres bild von
der epidemie in deutschland bekommen
größere klarheit über die dunkelziffer
der infektionen können pflegekräfte
häufiger testen um die ansteckungsgefahr
in krankenhäusern und heimlich zu senken
deswegen haben wir die kapazitäten für
eine umfassende testung schon
kontinuierlich ausgebaut und werden sie
weiter ausbauen
dennoch beenden können werden können
werden wir die korona pandemie letztlich
wohl nur mit einem impfstoff jedenfalls
nach allem was wir heute über das virus
wissen in mehreren ländern weltweit sind
forscher auf der suche
die bundesregierung hilft mit
finanzieller förderung damit auch der
forschungsstandort deutschland dabei ist
seine rolle spielen kann
genau so aber stehen wir auch finanziell
hinter internationalen initiativen wird
wie der impfstoff initiative cpi auch
für die medikamentenentwicklung und für
ein neues nationales forschungsnetzwerk
zu profit 19 hat die bundesregierung
kurzfristig erhebliche mittel zur
verfügung gestellt das hilft forschern
und ärzten an allen deutschen
universitätskliniken hand in hand an
dieser aufgabe zu arbeiten und wir
werden ja noch viele studien brauchen
dann auch
der zukunft antikörper studien dafür
sind wir also gut gerüstet
doch wissenschaft ist nie nationalen
wissenschaft dient der menschheit und
deshalb versteht es sich von selbst dass
wir medikamente oder ein impfstoff
gefunden getestet freigegeben und
einsatzbereit sind dass sie dann in
aller welt verfügbar und auch für alle
welt bezahlbar sein müssen
ein virus das sich in fast allen staaten
ausbreitet kann auch nur im
zusammenwirken aller staaten
zurückgedrängt und eingedämmt werden
für die bundesregierung ist die
internationale zusammenarbeit gegen das
virus herausragend wichtig wir stimmen
uns im kreis der europäischen union ab
genauso im rahmen der g7 und der g20 mit
der entscheidung den ärmsten 77 staaten
der welt alle zins und tilgungszahlungen
in diesem jahr zu stunden konnten wir
etwas druck von diesen hart geprüften
staatengruppen nehmen
aber bei dieser unterstützung wird es
natürlich nicht bleiben können für die
bundesregierung ist die zusammenarbeit
mit den staaten afrikas immer ein
schwerpunkt und in der korona krise
müssen wir sie noch verstärken
nicht nur in afrika nicht nur in afrika
aber gerade dort kommt es sehr auf die
arbeit der weltgesundheitsorganisation
wie heroin für die bundesregierung
betone ich die idee ist ein
unverzichtbarer partner und sie
unterstützen sie in ihrem mandat
meine damen und herren wenn wir uns hier
in deutschland die neuesten zahlen des
robert-koch-instituts ansehen dann
zeigen die indikatoren dass sie sich in
die richtige richtung entwickeln zb eine
verlangsamte infektions geschwindigkeit
täglich derzeit mehr genesene als
neuerkrankte das ist ein zwischenerfolg
aber gerade weil die zahlungen zahlen
hoffnungen auslösen sehe ich mich
verpflichtet zu sagen dieses
zwischenergebnis ist zerbrechlich wir
bewegen uns auf dünnem a ist man kann
auch sagen auf dünnem eis
die situation ist trügerisch und wir
sind noch lange nicht über den berg
denn wir müssen im kampf gegen das virus
immer im kopf haben die zahlen von heute
spiegeln das infektionsgeschehen von vor
etwa zehn bis zwölf tagen wieder die
heutige zahl der neuinfizierten sagt uns
also nicht wie es in einer oder zwei
wochen aussieht wenn wir zwischendurch
ein deutliches mehr an neuen kontakten
zugelassen haben liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich möchte diese gelegenheit
nutzen um deshalb noch einmal etwas
ausführlicher zu erläutern was mir
gerade sorge bereitet natürlich sind
politische entscheidungen immer teil
eines fortwährenden abwägungsprozesses
nach besten wissen und gewissen und das
gilt auch für die entscheidungen zur
bekämpfung der pandemie die er von
größter tragweite für das wohlergehen
der menschen in unserem lande sind und
in dieser so überaus wichtigen abwägung
die sich niemand weder im bund noch in
den bundesländern leicht macht das weiß
ich bin ich bei der bekämpfung der
korona des corona virus überzeugt wenn
wir gerade am anfang dieser pandemie
größtmögliche ausdauer disziplin
aufbringen dann werden wir in der lage
sein schneller wieder wirtschaftlich
das soziales und öffentliches leben zu
entfalten und zwar nachhaltig und zwar
schneller als wenn wir uns vor dem
hintergrund ermutigender
infektionszahlen gerade am anfang zu
schnell in falscher sicherheit wiegen
wenn wir also am anfang diszipliniert
sind werden wir es viel schneller
schaffen gesundheit und wirtschaft
gesundheit und soziales leben wieder
gleichermaßen leben zu können
auch dann wird das virus immer noch da
sein aber mit konzentration und ausdauer
gerade am anfang können wir vermeiden
von einem zum nächsten shutdown wechseln
oder gruppen von menschen monatelang von
allen anderen isolieren zu müssen und
mit furchtbaren zuständen und sagen
krankenhäusern zu leben wie es in
einigen anderen ländern leider der fall
sei die ausdauernde und konsequenter wir
am anfang der pandemie die
einschränkungen ertragen und damit das
infektionsgeschehen nach unten drücken
umso mehr denen wir nicht nur der
gesundheit der menschen sondern auch den
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen leben weil
wir dann wieder in der lage wären jede
infektionskette konsequent zu ermitteln
und so das virus zu beherrschen
diese überzeugung leitet mein handeln
ich sage ihnen deshalb ganz offen ich
trage die beschlüsse die bund und länder
am mittwoch letzter woche getroffen
haben
aus voller überzeugung mit doch ihre
umsetzung seither bereitet mir sorgen
sie wirkt auf mich in teilen wertvoll
sie wirkt auf mich in teilen sehr forsch
um nicht zu sagen zuvor
wenn ich das sage dann ändert das
natürlich kein jota daran dass ich die
hoheit der bundesländer die ihnen nach
unserer grundgesetzlich
festgeschriebenen föderalen
staatsordnung in vielen fragen zu kommt
natürlich auch beim
infektionsschutzgesetz aus voller
überzeugung möchte kein lothar unsere
föderale ordnung ist stark und damit
kein missverständnis entsteht das wollte
ich das jetzt noch mal deutlich sagen
gleichwohl sehe ich es als meine pflicht
anzumahnen geben nicht auf das prinzip
hoffnung zu vertrauen wenn ich davon
nicht überzeugt bin
und so manch in diesem sinne auch im
gespräch mit den ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten
denton und auch in diesem hohen hause
lassen sie uns jetzt das erreichte nicht
verspielen und ein rückschlag riskieren
es wäre jammerschade wenn uns die
voreilige hoffnung am ende bestraft
bleiben wir alle auf dem weg in die
nächste phase der pandemie klug und
vorsichtig das ist eine langstrecke bei
der uns nicht zu früh die kraft und die
luft ausgeht dürfen
und klar ist dass wir erst einmal nicht
zum alltag wie wir ihn vorchor
unerkannten zurückkehren können
der alltag wird einstweilen anders
aussehen auch dann wenn die derzeit
beratenden digitalen tracing modelle zum
einsatz kommen können auch die strengen
abstandsregeln die hygienevorschriften
auch die kontakt begrenzungen werden
weiter dazu gehört das betrifft
beispielsweise die öffnung von schulen
und kitas
die länder sind dabei die schrittweise
öffnung der schulen nun auch ganz
praktisch umzusetzen bzw vorzubereiten
und da wird es viel fantasie voller
tatkraft bedürfen
und ich danke heute schon allen die sich
dafür zurzeit einsetzen und ich weiß
dass das sehr sehr viele sind ich habe
am anfang von der größten
bewährungsprobe seit den anfangstagen
der bundesrepublik deutschland
gesprochen und das gilt leider auch für
die wirtschaft wie tief die einbußen am
ende des jahres sein werden und wie
lange sie anhalten wann die erholung
einsetzt das können wir heute noch nicht
seriös sagen denn auch das hängt
natürlich von unserem erfolg in der
auseinandersetzung mit dem bus die
pandemie hat uns in einer zeit gesunder
haushalte und starker reserven getroffen
jahre solider politik helfen uns jetzt
es geht jetzt darum unsere wirtschaft zu
stützen und einen schutzschirm für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
aufzuspannen millionen von anträgen auf
verschiedene hilfsprogramme sind
eingegangen millionen von menschen und
unternehmen haben bereits geld erhalten
wir konnten all diese gesetzlichen
maßnahmen schnell und mit überwältigen
mehrheit beschließen unsere
parlamentarische demokratie ist stark
sie ist leistungsfähig und in
krisenzeiten äußerst schnell auch
gestern abend haben wir im
koalitionsausschuss noch einmal weitere
maßnahmen beschlossen sie sind darüber
informiert
doch all unsere bemühungen auf
nationaler ebene können letztlich nur
dann erfolgreich sein wenn wir auch
gemeinsam in europa erfolgreich sind
sie haben mich oft sagen hören hier in
diesem haus auch deutschland kann es auf
dauer nur gut gehen wenn es auch europa
gut geht
mir ist es mit diesem satz auch heute
wieder sehr sehr ernst sie drückt sich
das praktisch aus zum beispiel haben wir
mehr als 200 patienten aus italien
frankreich oder den niederlanden in
deutschen intensivstationen behandelt
wir haben medizinisches material zum
beispiel nach italien geliefert oder
auch noch spanien und zusammen mit
unseren bürgern auch tausende
gestrandete andere europäerinnen und
europäer aus aller welt zurück nach
hause geholt dafür übrigens ein
herzliches dankeschön allen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern im
auswärtigen amt man glaubt gar nicht wie
viele deutsche sich außerhalb der
eigenen landesgrenzen befinden aber wir
konnten auch vielen europäern helfen
danke dafür
und wir haben auch gemeinsam gehandelt
um den massiven dem massiven einbruch
der europäischen wirtschaft zu begegnen
wir tun das mit einem paket von
hilfsmaßnahmen für unternehmen und
beschäftigte in höhe von immerhin 500
milliarden euro dass unser
finanzminister olaf scholz und die
anderen finanzminister in der
euro-gruppe vor zwei wochen vereinbart
haben jetzt geht es darum diese 500
milliarden auch wirklich verfügbar zu
machen dafür wird auch der deutsche
bundestag noch beschlüsse fassen müssen
und ich würde mich freuen wenn wir sagen
könnten zum 16 ist das geld dann auch
wirklich da denn es geht hier um hilfe
für kleine und mittlere unternehmen
das gilt hier um vorsorgliche
kreditlinien und es geht hier auch um
kurzarbeitergeld für das vielleicht
einige mitgliedstaaten nicht die
finanziellen ressourcen haben was aber
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern dort
sehr helfen sie fordern einige unserer
partner aber auch in der deutschen
politischen diskussion angesichts der
schweren krise gemeinsam schulden mit
gemeinsamer haftung aufzunehmen diese
frage wird auch bei der video konferenz
des europäischen rates heute nachmittag
sicherlich wieder eine rolle spielen
nehmen wir an es sei die zeit und der
politische wille zu gemeinsamer
verschuldung da und er bestünde wirklich
dann müssten alle nationalen parlamente
in der europäischen union und auch der
deutsche bundestag entscheiden
die eu verträge so zu ändern dass ein
teil des budgetrechts auf die
europäische ebene übertragen und dort
demokratisch kontrolliert würde das wäre
ein zeit ordner und schwieriger prozess
und keiner der in der aktuellen lage
direkt helfen könnte denn es geht jetzt
darum schnell zu hilfe
und schnell instrumente in der hand zu
haben die die folgen der krise lindern
können und dazu wird beim heutigen
europäischen rat auch darüber beraten
wie wir in europa gemeinsam in der zeit
nach den strengsten einschränkungen
vorgehen wollen wir wollen schnell in
europa handeln denn wir brauchen
natürlich instrumente um die folgen der
krise in allen mitgliedstaaten
überwinden zu können
ich halte es in diesem zusammenhang erst
einmal für wichtig dass die europäische
kommission jetzt und in den nächsten
wochen fortlaufend prüft wie die
verschiedenen bereiche der wirtschaft in
europa von der krise betroffen sind und
welcher handlungsbedarf sich daraus
ergibt dies betrifft also auch die
unmittelbare hilfe für die europäische
wirtschaft ein europäisches
konjunkturprogramm könnte in den
nächsten zwei jahren die nötigen
aufschwung unterstützen
und deshalb werden wir dafür auch
arbeiten in unserem heutigen beratungen
wird es noch nicht darum gehen bereits
die details festzulegen oder über den
umfang schon zu entscheiden
doch eines ist schon klar wir sollten
bereit sein im geiste der solidarität
über einen begrenzten zeitraum hinweg
ganz andere das deutlich höhere beiträge
zum europäischen haushalt zu leisten
denn wir wollen dass alle mit in staaten
in der europäischen union sich
wirtschaftlich wieder erholen können
ein solches ein solches von dem kopf
sollte allerdings von vornherein mit dem
europäischen haushalts zusammengedacht
werden denn der gemeinsame europäische
haushalt ist das seit jahrzehnten
bewährte instrument solidarische
finanzierung gemeinsamer aufgaben in der
europäischen union
darüber hinaus werde ich heute darauf
drängen dass sich der europäische rat
schon bald mit grundsätzlichen fragen
befasst wo müssen wir auf europäischer
ebene noch enger zusammenarbeiten
wo braucht die europäische union
zusätzliche kompetenzen welche
strategischen fähigkeiten müssen wir in
zukunft in europa haben oder halten
nicht nur bei der finanzpolitik der
digital politik und beim binnenmarkt
könnten wir diese union vertiefen auch
in der migrationspolitik der
rechtsstaatlichkeit der europäischen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
oder beim klimaschutz ist europäische
solidarität gefragt herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen für uns in
deutschland ist das bekenntnis zum
vereinten europa teil unserer
staatsräson
das ist kein stoff für sonntagsreden
sondern das ist ganz praktisch
wir sind eines schicksals menschen und
dies muss europa jetzt in dieser
ungeahnten herausforderung der pandemie
beweisen diese pandemie trifft alle
aber nicht alle gleich wenn wir nicht
aufpassen dient sie all denen als
vorband die die spaltung der
gesellschaft betreibt europa ist nicht
europa wenn es sich nicht auch als
europa versteht
europa ist nicht europa wenn es nicht
füreinander einsteht in zeiten
unverschuldeter not
wir haben in dieser krise auch die
aufgabe zu zeigen wer wir als europa
sein wollen und so bin ich am ende
meiner rede wieder beim gedanken des
zusammenhalts angekommen was in europa
gilt ist auch für uns in deutschland das
wichtigste so paradox es klingt in
wochen in denen die verhaltensregeln uns
weit auseinander gezwungen haben und
distanz stadtnähe nötig ist haben wir
zusammen gehalten und durch zusammenhalt
gemeinsam geschafft dass sich das virus
auf seinem weg durch deutschland und
europa immerhin verlangsamt hat das kann
keine regierung einfach anordnen
auf so etwas kann eine regierung
letztlich nur hoffen das ist nur möglich
wenn bürgerinnen und bürger mit herz und
vernunft etwas für ihre mitmenschen tun
für irland
nennen sie es für das große ganze
mich macht das unendlich dankbar und ich
wünsche mir dass wir auch so weiter
durch diese nächste zeit gehen
sie wird noch länger sehr schwer bleiben
aber gemeinsam davon bin ich nach diesen
ersten wochen der pandemie überzeugt
wird es uns gelingen diese gigantische
herausforderung zu meistern gemeinsam
als gesellschaft gemeinsam in europa
vielen dank
keine entwarnung also von der kanzlerin
im gegenteil sie betonte man müsse noch
sehr lange mit dem virus leben
die situation sei trügerisch mann soll
noch lange nicht über den berg auch wenn
einige zahlen das vermuten lassen
der forscher hat die umsetzung der
lockerungsmaßnahmen in einigen
bundesländern so die kritik der
kanzlerin
sie bleibt also bei ihrer linie dass sie
weiter macht und vorsichtig vorgehen
will